あっち一体梅雨はいつ終わるんでしょうか厚みそうですというわけでみなさん杖に来
ましたねいつ出したんだけどね結構昔車
部屋衣替えしました前までここら辺で撮ってたんですけどちょっと夏ということでゴザ
をひいてここでまとってましたものとか増やしていく予定なんでよろしくっていうこと
はどうでもよくてですねいつ出したでしたっけ2年前ですね私に年前にポケモンカード
にはまってします
ポケモンカードにはまってしまいました助けてくださいっていう動画2年前ぐらいに
出してたんですけども
ポケモンカード最近行ってないとポケモンカードやったことない人きましたよ
ビッグウェーブがこちら設けない
ああ
きました何でしょう今回ちょっと多いですね9種類ワンコインで始められまして
500円スタートデッキデー
懐かしい私初の一つは最近はポケカちょいちょいやってるんですけども
どうやって始めたらて card ポケモンカードやったことなかったんですよ
2年前までそのポケモンカードっていう存在
がめっちゃ知ってたけどねほとっつきにくいと言いますか変なゲームでよく寝みたいな
ところがあって全然ならなかったしやりたくもなかったんですけども
2年前にポケモンカードのデッキが500円で売られてて500円500円だったら
そんなもうすぐできるじゃんと思ってなんとなくワンコインで買ってみたところから
全てが始まりました
それ以来まあモード版有りと言いますがまぁ忙しいとき
さすがにできないんですけども定期的に途切れることなく楽しませていただいて早2年
経ったんですけども今日からまた500円で始められるデッキが90年も販売された
みたいで
案件じゃないで涼んで pr 活動と走るわけじゃないので
梅雨に共発現させていただきますけどこちら
絶対言えない気か絶対無理だな絶対いや無理だと思ったらできないとあああああ
無理だと思ったらできないけどそれをやるのは私ですおっちーシーアがー
[拍手]
ちょっと1個ずつ見ていきましょうか炎デッキ顔がいいんですね
これが水デッキホエールを草デッキの c バーナー面倒だしてピカチュウ雷のピッチ
です
右上ですねまぁこれぞ6にも超タイプ超能力もできる創造シールとかたジュダルドンと
いうドラゴンができるってことは金で進ま柄だとそんな強くないかも知れません6軽い
を
灯タイプ格闘的ですで最近のヤドランは音樂
タイプなんですねこれヤドランなんですけどめちゃくちゃないか顔怖いですね開く
タイプのデッキです
ああ可愛い v 可能性も言えないです6色です黄色がない時でいろんなカードゲーム
やってきたんですけどもだいたいデッキッグ買うと1000円くらいするんですそれが
なんとかなぁ半分の500円ワンコインで買えるということでね本当にねあの趣味ない
ととか大陰線で僕の周りとか
岡趣味ただけなんですけども君だけなんですけどもなんか趣味のないとかハードいうの
がやったことない人とか言ったら本当に今がはじめどきだと思いますな方がメイン
チャンネルでカードの障害になってしないですからこそよっ本のことですよっぽどの時
なんでこんなこと言ってますからねちょっとなカメ見てみましょうか
これだけ海パンも始めれるんですよね
とダメージカウンター水ダメ入るとこれを載せるみたいなダメージカウンターとかも
入ってますこれで550円でしょ
可愛いやつオールもん顔だよはずめねもう色んなカードが入ってるわけなんですけどの
ポケ峰母が遊ぶ時に必要な顔が大抵入ってるんですよ
溶接工入って一番体じゃこれこので焔が一番強いですから
溶接工やばいでしょこのあ
強い気がしますちょっと私独断と偏見でどのできる通勤前調査してみますね
相性とかもあるんですけども相性は抜きで分前にカードの強さだけ見るとどれが強いか
ちょっと調べてみます茶目にも炎を上げてみたんですけどほどヤバイ多分山で一番強い
ですねチェックさあ見てみますもう oc まだねー
7:00マミー取るだビードロ方を進化させて戦いそうだなこれ
eye-fi 方へ
雨は種はまあまあままです
水着ます今後知らないと見てたらカードを見せられてもよくわかんないよねもう吠える
をねぇこいつ hp が高いから強いんですよねうん
だいたい草とどっこいどっこいって感じですで雷ですぴっかっていうが入ってるから
これは外で
t 消されている感じがあります気が散ら猛抗議文サンドバックが付いてますからこの
パッチですよお母様には誰も勝てません
クイックボールが入ってるんだと外れわからないと思うけど打ったパン強い
雷できてちょっとっ
すごいけどたぶん今と焔が一番強いですよ格闘見ていきましょう
ルカリオサワーはイケメンなんで行け連絡としてはなかなか強いような気がしますマジ
でかっこいいなぁばかりを東大もできてからも戦ってナンボみたいな感じの出来なん
ですかね
どうなんだろう実は強いなぁこの時グラうどんとか言ってるんですよね
強いはクイックボール入ってればびっくぼるっていうのが今一番大事なんですよ
東台まで必要ですとか普通にあっクリッキー宿なんてああ
って感じないい感じだと思います中間的な強さ
算数で鉄壁なことが鋼日記見ていきましょうああああを大大大水中強いことメタル操作
っていうかうち強いですけど肌にも結構強いぞこれ超見ていきましょう
状態部の出来ということで食べちょっとテクニカルな戦い方が求められるんでしょうね
知らんけど
ちょっと読めんな使い方しないみたいなところからちょっとわからん最後無職です
6色デッキとはまでを使いやすいべきだと思うんですよね
ev がめちゃくちゃかわいいですこれ使いやすそうだなーっ
すごくでこれめっちゃエネルギーから来るに入ってるってますを号数ってことでキー
ヤーちょっと難しいですねえっとパッドさ
やってみた感じですねあのう
どれも一緒や惚れムズイなぁ現像パッと見た感じどれもいいとこありますねほんと綺麗
なバランスで作られてると思います
それで僕の独断が片言で行くと上の子がちょっと強そうかなと思いました
下の4つも全然強いですけどもなんとなくつか皆さんをつけると
上が設定したが
強いです全部ちゃえなんか俺の周りでも2年前
なんか俺が紹介したせいか知らないんですけどもポケモンカード部分
うわーってなった時があったんですよもう全国もう全国からポケモンカードが
売り切れる現象が起きたんですけどもまぁ最近今チラーと見てみるとやっぱり今はやっ
てないよって人とかやってんだけど辞めちゃってる人がいるんですけどもやり直す
チャンスでとしても行った
都内1
チャンスですもう500円でも一戦はだした後できますから
8 pot してもやってる人間からすると慎吾増える事ってすごいいいことだと思う
んであとね簡単たぶん普通の人間だったらこれねあん10分あったら覚えれます買う時
にやってた人間みたいな僕からすると3分で覚えましたってくらいめちゃくちゃやる
こと簡単なんでまずはこういうスタート的とか買って覚えてみるのは良いと思います皆
500円ですよ
本日に出そうだけどご飯が祀ればを遊べるって言う本当に歴史の長いカードゲームと
いうことを知ったので私もねちょっとね人生通して楽しめるんじゃないかなと思って
ずっとこそに続けてるんですけども
今回ここ100円また販売されているということで改めて紹介してみました
乙的にはまたちょっと人口増えてほしいですねまぁ今を全然人気あるんですけども
もっといろんな人に楽しんでもらえたらいいなと
思っております
ご存知初めてですあの今ですねー
ポケモンカードが
500円で始めるんですけど
よりますやりますやっぱ
あっはーる elr